today on the matt well show christina
aguilera performs in a family-friendly
concert quote-unquote with a strap-on
dildo this is just one example of
extreme over-the-top debauchery and
degeneracy being totally normalized and
institutionalized in our culture we're
going to talk about where all this leads
and what we can do about it today also
karen jean-pierre laughs off any
concerns about her boss's senility the
white house meets with defund the police
advocates as crime ravages communities
across the country a twitter thread goes
viral detailing the horrifying realities
of gender affirming surgeries quote
unquote in our daily cancellation lizzo
is forced to apologize and change and
reissue her latest single due to
controversy over the language in the
song but you'll never guess which word
has people so upset seriously you'll
never guess all of that and more today
on the matt wall show
[Applause]
[Music]
you know the left is so aggressively
declaring war on reality to the point
that asking simple questions blows their
mind uh as we discovered of course in my
film what is a woman but now there's an
organization that i love and i've been
following for years uh the pro-life
group live action led by my good friend
leela rose and they've just released an
incredible new video campaign that also
asks a very simple question what is
abortion okay in this we've found this
to be a very effective tactic you know
it's just ask basic questions and this
applies to the gender issue and
especially applies to the life issue
which is what live action is doing here
you can see the videos at what is
abortion.com and here's the thing uh
these videos can turn the tide in the
abortion war the videos are on one level
very simple but they're also they're
also brilliantly crafted uh and this is
a lot of what live action does seems
simple on the surface but there's a lot
of depth to it they feature former
abortionists simply explaining in matter
of fact terms the four most prominent
abortion procedures with medical
animation and that's it this is just
this is what abortion is when people see
the violence committed against children
many of them change their minds after
watching the what is abortion videos 19
of pro-choice women is selected abortion
should never be legal and and the number
of people who said abortion should never
be allowed skyrocketed 21
from 25 to 46 so this is a tactic the
strategy that really works and it's a
strategy that just emphasizes the truth
that's all bottom line is that if
everyone in america watched these videos
we would have a pro-life country where
children are more protected so go to
whatisabortion.com check out the videos
and more importantly share them with
everyone you know these tools are in
your hands
use them
well after a pride filled day in los
angeles on saturday complete with naked
gay men and bondage gear parading
through the streets and acting out their
sexual fetishes in front of children
while morbidly obese drag queens stood
on parade floats and shouted about lube
into megaphones festivities culminated
in a grand finale musical performance
the la pride in the park music festival
billed itself as an all-ages
kid-friendly event
which in fact the entire all the pride
parades and all the pride events claim
to be all ages and kid-friendly but we
know what these people mean when they
say kid friendly essentially a
kid-friendly activity is any activity
they feel like engaging in with kids
present
they don't judge whether something is
kid-friendly before doing it in front of
kids they do it in front of kids and
then declare after the fact that it was
kid-friendly because they did it in
front of kids
and so it perhaps should not be a
surprise that former pop star christina
aguilera took to the stage during this
concert to perform a song called xxx
alongside a transgender singer named kim
petras and for the performance aguilera
wore a green hulk suit and a strap-on
dildo
she then simulated masturbation as she
danced across the stage while drunkenly
shouting the lyrics to what just may be
the dumbest song ever written and
there's a lot of competition for that
title but listening
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
six six six
[Music]
yes the song largely consists of the
word sex repeated over and over again
there are also graphic descriptions of
various sex acts
in the song but in case you aren't
picking up on the theme they continue to
shout the word sex in the refrain like
do you get it this song's about sex you
know sex aren't you impressed aren't we
edgy isn't this an edgy song guys did
you hear us we said the word sex
what they lack in wit or subtlety
they'll make up for by beating you over
the head with a sledgehammer until
you've lost enough brain cells to
actually enjoy a song like this maybe by
the time your your mental capacity
matches that of like a dishrag or joe
biden you might find yourself tapping
your foot and nodding along to the song
it is interesting though to consider
that janet jackson was around the age
christina aguilera is now when she
performed at the super bowl in the early
2000s
and back then it was a major scandal a
huge national story when an aging pop
star showed her nipple for a few seconds
now an aging pop star can gyrate across
the stage in front of kids while
screaming about sex and waving her dildo
around and it's barely noticed by
anybody apart from a few approving
write-ups by the entertainment rags now
that's understandable in a certain way
it's difficult to keep up with all of
the shameless perversion and depravity
especially during pride month after all
this happened just a day after postmates
which is a food delivery service owned
by uber
ran an ad introducing their new quote
bottom friendly menu now i can't even
play most of this ad and if i could play
it i still wouldn't play most of it but
here's just enough
to uh get the gist of it and the main
reason i want to play this for you is
that if you haven't seen it and i
describe it you will think i'm making it
up but i am not
watch
what are you eating this pride
well if you're a top it seems like you
can eat whatever you want
but if you're a bottom you're expected
to starve
not this pride introducing the bottom
friendly menu from postmates
we teamed up with dr evan goldstein from
bespoke surgical to bring you a menu of
bottom friendly foods backed by science
insoluble fiber won't help you feel
cubes so avoid things like whole grains
sweet bran cauliflower potatoes legumes
hold up are you just fully diving into
those beans
like i said subtle subtle as always um
now to be totally clear about what you
just heard this is a major food delivery
service which now has a section on its
website for food items you should eat
before engaging in sodomy they have a
sodomy section on their menu
essentially they imagined what would
what it would have been like if sodom
and gomorrah had doordash
and then they went and just made that
dream a reality
meanwhile lost in the shuffle between
the sodomy menu and christina aguilera
in a dildo was the latest episode of
rupaul's dragway drag race in which
nancy pelosi
wandered onto stage to deliver a canned
stump speech about the wonders of drag
because these days politicians actually
have canned stump speeches about the
wonders of drag
watch
please give a warm drag race welcome to
the speaker of the house nancy pelosi
[Music]
welcome back
my honor to be here
to say to all of you how proud we all
are of you
thank you for the joy and beauty you
bring to the world oh your freedom of
expression of yourselves in drag is what
america is all about
everybody on that stage by the way is
completely wasted including and
especially nancy pelosi now
drag is what america is all about says
the speaker of the house
the men who stormed the beaches of
normandy
thought they were fighting for freedom
family righteousness truth
turns out they were mostly fighting for
drag
many brave souls have died to protect
the sacred right of men to cross-dress
as characters from nightmare before
christmas because that's always the
preferred drag aesthetic for some reason
so so uh so what's going on here what
are we witnessing
i think there are two things that are
related
one is that our culture has been
coarsened to the point of non-existence
now cultures are supposed to be living
breathing vibrant things cultures are
rich with tradition and history
a culture preserves the heritage of your
ancestors and leaves a legacy for future
descendants
a culture is the summation of the art
and history and traditions and
accomplishments of a people a people's
culture is supposed to tell you what
those people value what they care about
who they are
that is not our culture
because we don't have one ours is an
anti-culture
our culture is the absence of culture
our culture is a giant
black
hole from which no light can escape
the left isn't concerned with building
anything making anything preserving
anything creating anything instead they
destroy that's all they do
even the music doesn't exist for its own
sake our pop stars they don't make music
they make anti-music
the music is a testament to what it
isn't
that's the only point of the music is
what it isn't
we have pop stars shouting the word sex
while running around the stage with
dildos not because this is the kind of
music they want to make but because it's
the opposite of the kind of music they
don't want to make or anyone to make
namely beautiful and meaningful music
music that points to truth
to the eternal
to the transcendent as all art is
supposed to do
not anti-art though
this is the case with everything in our
anti-culture
everything is broken down and replaced
with nothing
words are emptied of meaning but not
infused with any new meaning
everything is nothing
and nothing is meant to mean anything
the other point is that we're now
witnessing the institutionalization of
debauchery
institutionalized
debauchery
when uber is making ads promoting anal
sex and former mickey mouse club pop
stars are running around with dildos and
the speaker of the house is appearing on
stage with drag queens it means that
debauchery and perversion and depravity
have been totally institutionalized
you cannot rebel against the system by
acting like an insane stupid sex-crazed
fiend
because that is the system that's what
the system is all about
the bad news about this is that it means
that our institutions are completely
gone we have lost them they are just
gone
but the good news
is that the more that this stuff is
promoted by high-ranking politicians and
faceless corporations
the less rebellious and interesting and
unique it seems that's why the perverts
are growing increasingly desperate to
shock and offend us and the harder they
try the more difficult it is for them
all of their antics are bored and tired
and cliched
now there may have been a time when drag
queens represented a rebellion of sorts
but not anymore not when nancy pelosi is
standing there with them
these days if you want to rebel against
the system you have to do it by
rejecting all of those things
the most rebellious thing you can do is
lead a good decent normal life
rooted in moral truth and sanity
that's the most rebellious thing you
want to be a rebel that's what you do
that's the advantage we have now in the
culture i think anyone who wants to
rebel against the system anyone who
wants to stick their middle finger up to
the man or the them or however the man
identifies these days has to do it by
rejecting the degeneracy and moral
corruption
that the system peddles
that again is the good news
that we are the counter culture now
we are the rebels
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know what i hate most of all in the
entire world it's it's spending time at
the auto parts store you don't need to
waste hours and cumulative years of your
life at the auto parts store studies
show that the average person will spend
17 years of their lives
walking around auto parts store that is
a fact and that's why you need
rockauto.com instead with the ever
increasing number of car makes and
models it is now impossible to stock all
the parts you need in a traditional
chain storefront why indoor often
pointless or seemingly intimidating
questions about the specifications of
your vehicle only to have the counterman
order the parts on his computer anyway
you don't have to deal with that don't
deal with that damn counterman just go
to rockauto.com at home in your pocket
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com and shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they have everything from
engine control modules and brake parts
to tail lamps motor oil even new carpet
whether it's your classic or your daily
driver get everything you need in a few
easy clicks delivered directly to your
door cut the counter man out completely
the rockauto.com catalog is unique and
remarkably easy to navigate quickly see
all the parts available for your vehicle
and choose the brand specifications and
prices you prefer best of all prices at
rockauto.com are always reliably low and
same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers so go to rockauto.com
right now see all the parts available
for your car truck and remember as
always to write walsh in there how did
you hear about us box so they know that
i sent you
all right um
last night was a lot of fun by the way
we had our i don't know if i'm supposed
to talk about this yet but i am we had
our red carpet uh premiere of tara on
the prairie i know i'm not supposed to
say much about the film tara on the
prairie but i i think i can say
that it's a it was very good i'll say
i'll have more to say about it later um
after the premiere on daily wire tonight
but uh is i have uh high expectations
when it comes to westerns i'm a bit of a
western
snob um i i'm a harsh judge of westerns
especially modern westerns
and there are certain things they do in
modern westerns that really annoy me so
i'm i'm always looking for those i'm
very sensitive to them and none of that
was there it's very good movie um
my first time walking down any kind of
red carpet and i will say that it's not
my favorite environment in the world and
i'm not very good at it but i i think
everyone knew ahead of time that i
wouldn't be you know because you walk
down and you go to each
person there's like in the media they
have a question and then you're supposed
to have a little pithy response and you
have this little back and forth it's
like one little bit of small talk after
another
which is not my forte so i just walked
down and i had one word so matt what do
you what do you think about all this
being on the red carpet that's good
it's fine
carpet's red
all right thanks for stopping by and
that's that was the whole thing and we
get to the end of the red carpet and um
they actually said to me
we get all the way to the end and
there's this like
you gotta stop for pictures the whole
way it's just a nightmare okay i'll be
honest like that part of it is it's my
it's my hell amazing my hell is is a red
carpet for all eternity and we get to
the end of it and um
there's this uh moving camera and they
say that uh my wife was with me
and they said this is your glamour shot
and so we need you to do something big
and creative for the glamour shot
and i looked at them and i this is the
one time in my life i've been tempted to
say do you know who i am that was my one
my one time i wanted to pull that line
out
you this is for me you want me to do it
something big and creative for a glamour
shot
not going to happen
so i just stood there
stone faced and then well and then they
did their glamour shot and i walked away
but other than that a lot more to say
about the film when i'm allowed to say
it uh one other quick note also not to
have too many things we're promoting all
at once but we've got a lot a lot going
on here at the daily wire and also today
is the release of my book what is a
woman
now you've seen the film what is a woman
or if you haven't seen it then go to
what is woman.com and subscribe and
watch it
um and the book is coming out today as
well and go to amazon
and uh definitely i would ask you to buy
it on amazon there are other places you
can buy it also but i i would prefer you
buy it on amazon so we can get it all
the way to the top again and we know how
the amazon employees are going to we
know how much they're going to love that
so why buy the book number one it's well
not number one but it is you will be
trolling amazon and amazon employees and
you're gonna make them cry so that is a
benefit
but the real number one reason about it
is that um in the book i had the
opportunity to kind of go into more
detail about um some of the things that
we
have to um touch on only briefly in the
movie 90-minute film
so you only have you know there's only
so much space to work with
and so the book covers a lot of the same
basic story but you're able to go into
more detail what's going on behind the
scenes go into more detail about the
stories of a lot of these people that we
talked to in the film
and so definitely go to uh amazon and
pick up that book what is a woman all
right
we'll start here karen jean-pierre was
on cnn and uh the media is finally
asking this question
that's the
cover is blown now and everybody knows
that joe biden's losing his mind so
karen jean pair was asked on cnn
whether joe biden has the mental
cognizance required
to run for president again and here was
her answer
does the president have the stamina
physically and mentally do you think to
continue on even after 2024. you're
asking me this question oh my gosh he's
the president of the united states you
know he i can't even keep up with it we
just got back from new mexico we just
got back um from california uh that is
i
i
that is not a question that we should be
even asking just look at the work that
he does and look what he's how he's
delivering uh for the american public
look that what that that that article
that we're talking about is hearsay it's
salacious that's not what we care about
we care about how we going to deliver
for the american people how are we going
to make their lives better that's what
the president talks about that is his
focus
and that's where we're going to continue
uh to focus on
she is so bad at this this is what you
get i'm not saying she's a diversity a
diversity hire but uh
she is a diversity hire and this is what
you get when you hire someone i mean
it's it's yeah she's uh
she what is huge she's the first black
female
uh
bisexual press secretary
so she's got that going for her but the
other problem is that she can't
you know um
speak i mean she can't really answer
questions and she she somehow is
unprepared and caught off guard
by the questions that she should be the
most prepared to answer so when you're
the press secretary for a president who
is losing his mind in front of the world
and everybody sees it
and he can't string together one
sentence like cannot do it can't do it
um when that happens then you should be
prepared to answer questions about that
like you you should have a an answer
ready
and her answer is well she he's the
president
well we know he's the president that's
the problem
as if the very fact that he is the
president
means that he's prepared to be the
president well if he wasn't prepared to
be the president then how is he
president
and the fact that he's president again
is part of the point because not only
does it allow all of us to see his
cognitive decline and everybody can see
you're not fooling anybody
everyone can see it but not only that
but um
we are also aware that
it
being president only makes the problem
worse
so
it's
the problem is is exacerbated by the
fact that like if you're losing your
mind
and you're just and you're retired and
you're on a rocking chair on your front
porch
then that's not a big problem for the
country
but if you're in the oval office and you
lose your mind that is a big problem for
the country
and also just the fact of having an
office is going to make the mental
problem worse
so it's a self-perpetuating issue
because there's a lot of
even with joe biden going to bed at 6 00
p.m every night and waking up at nine or
whatever he's doing it's still
you know you're not going to get all the
rest you should be getting when you're
when you're in this state
it's a high pressure job a lot's being
asked of you
even if you're not doing any of the
things that are asked of you still
you're being asked to do a lot of things
and um i mean just look at i i made this
point
well i've been making this point all
along as you know as i've been as i've
been hammering on this uh
getting on my this is my one of my stump
speeches about how we you know
we should not be electing anybody over
the age of 75 there should be an age
limit on it that to me is incredibly
obvious
but also
just look at
every president in the modern era except
for donald trump he's the one exception
every other one they get out of office
after eight years or even after their
first four years in office and they look
like they've aged 20 years
look at uh you know obama when he first
entered office versus when he left
george bush same thing
it's only eight years they look like
they aged you know they come out looking
like they're in their late 70s
that's how much the office ages you
so then you take that effect and you
apply it to someone who's already 78
when he when he enters office and was
already senile
what happens then well we're seeing it
uh more news from the white house is
from the daily wire says while the
nation has been reeling from rising
crime during the biden administration uh
defund the police advocates have been
visiting the white house or meeting with
white house aides according to white
house visitor logs some of the activists
have included rashad robinson the
president of color of change carmen
rojas the president ceo of the
marguerite casey foundation um and then
the co-founder of something called black
voters matter and others as well someone
with al sharpton's national action
network
rojas tweeted last year so many people
are twisting themselves into word
pretzels they say we need justice in one
breath and not all police are bad and
next we must be unwavering in our
commitment to freedom the best way to
realize it is to defund the police and
support abolition
period
um so they the white house and the
democrat party they have not completely
you know evicted the defund the police
people they have not exiled them out
into the wilderness
as much as i suspect a lot of them would
like to be able to do that they can't
this is who you've made your bed with
you're not they're they're part of the
club
really important part prominent part
and as we get into uh 2022 in the
midterms and everything and we're
already seeing this but but you know
this is
obviously the economy is a big is a big
issue
that republicans should be hammering the
democrats with and they are
but i think even more than that
crime
and gender insanity i'd put those two
things right at the top
and that puts the democrats in the most
indefensible situation
and these are also the things that
people live with every day and are
worried about
and you look to the democrats and they
either have no answers or
they are in fact they are intentionally
making these problems worse
so people live especially if you live in
cities you live with the crime problem
every day it's the kind of thing you
worry about
when if you have a family if your kids
are out you know if you have a wife your
wife's got this you worry about them
falling victim to this
just like as much as democrats
pretend not to realize this
um with the gender insanity
this is something every parent now
worries about i mean every parent i've
talked to
especially the last couple of weeks i've
talked to many many parents
got emails and everything they're
terrified of this of their kids falling
victim to the gender insanity so these
two issues
democrats they have no response
to call them vulnerable would be a
massive understatement
this also from the daily wire says amber
heard took a shot at social media users
and a jury that largely sided with her
ex-husband johnny depp during action's
first interview since a verdict was
rendered in the couple's highly
publicized defamation case
the jury of course found that heard
defamed
depp in an op-ed about domestic violence
awarding him a total of 15 million
dollars in monetary
damages though was dropped to a total of
10 million due to virginia law and says
they're first talking to the deja first
interview and uh is she contrite is she
asking for forgiveness is she taking any
accountability is she sharing any of the
blame whatsoever
uh of course not let's listen
even somebody who is
sure
i'm deserving
of
all this hate in vitriol
even if you think
that i'm lying you still couldn't look
me in the eye and tell me that you think
on social media there's been a fair
representation you cannot tell me
that you think that this has been fair
um i mean we can tell you that and that
is what we're telling you amber i'm
afraid to say that's exactly what we can
say
and i think that this
one of the things that's
interesting here especially with amber
heard's reaction
who is she's just
she just lost i'm not even sure how this
works legally that you lose on a
defamation case
but you're doubling down
and still repeating the same claims you
just got sued over
and you lost that case so can you get
sued again for it i don't know
but um
to watch her reaction she's just stunned
she like didn't think this was possible
that she would actually lose
and that's why she told these braids and
lies in the first place
knowing that she was telling the lies
about someone who had the
financial ability to hold her
accountable
and most people don't that's why people
get defamed all the time in this country
especially by the media the media loves
defaming people and most people just
don't have the
financial capacity don't have the
resources to do anything about it
because it's very very expensive and
it's a risky proposition also to try to
sue someone for defamation it's very
hard to win
you open yourself up to you know counter
suits and everything else
so she knew that she was doing this
to someone who had the ability
and had the resources to take her to
court she did it anyway
brazenly
and now she's shocked and stunned and i
think really shocked and son not just
pretending
because this is she's lived this life of
privilege and we're starting to see
someone who's lived a life of privilege
in this in this bubble um and for the
first time the privilege didn't she
tried to cash her privilege card in and
it didn't it didn't it didn't work
tried to cash her privilege check and it
bounced for the first time in her life
and she doesn't know what to do about it
and what's the privilege that she had i
think we should be clear about this
is it uh white privilege
well it's got nothing to do with with
her race really this is a dispute
between two white people anyway so it's
not white privilege
part of it is money you know okay so
she's a hollywood actor she's got a lot
of money there's real privilege that
comes with that
but also she has attractive female
privilege
which of all the different kinds of
privileges in the modern western world
or anywhere in the world that is
probably number one
that is the number one form of privilege
if you're female
and physically attractive
you have advantages that nobody else
will ever have
i mean you have a path laid out in your
life that is automatically going to be
so much easier
than almost anybody else just just by by
virtue of that
and then you take attractive female and
you have money i mean this is the this
is
the most
comfortable and luxurious type of life
on offer like this is the on the menu of
options for for human existence
that's that's number one in terms of
comfort luxury
living a pain-free life
and so she's simply just never been held
accountable
nobody's ever called her on anything
it's their first time and she doesn't
know how to handle it and that is very
fun to watch
our move into nbc news articles as
washington commanders otherwise known as
the redskins head coach ron rivera on
friday
fined his defensive coordinator jack del
rio a hundred thousand dollars for
calling the january sixth attack of the
us capital a dust-up and referring to
the racial justice protests
of 2020 as a summer of riots which of
course is exactly what it was and we all
saw
in a statement attributed to rivera and
posted on the on the commander's twitter
page the nfl head coach said he was
disappointed in del rio's comments and
said they hurt the community
um the statement said as we saw last
night in the hearings what happened on
the the capitol to the capitol on
january 6 2021 was an act of domestic
terrorism a group of citizens attempted
to overturn the results of a free and
fair election blah blah blah uh coach
del rio did apologize for his comments
on wednesday and he understands the
distinction between the events of that
dark day and peaceful protests which are
the hallmark of our democracy
because the blm riots were peaceful
protests of course
um but they're gonna find him a hundred
thousand dollars just for exercising his
free speech
so he talked about how you have
privilege in america well this is
someone who doesn't have even though
he's a nfl coach gets paid a lot of
money
uh he's a man and most importantly he's
uh
i guess
a conservative or a conservative
adjacent
in fact that doesn't even matter he he
said something that liberals disagree
with and so there's no privilege there
and so he's fined a hundred thousand
dollars just for expressing his opinion
um an opinion which by the way is not
really even an opinion it's just a
statement of fact especially when it
comes to the blm rights they were riots
they were by every measure far worse
than what happened at the capitol that's
a fact
but
fact or opinion or both
it's also this is a point of view shared
by
the vast majority of the nfl audience
okay i guarantee you if you polled the
nfl audience the people who actually sit
down and watch football games every
sunday you were to poll them about the
blm riots and ask them were those uh
just peaceful protests or were they
horrible riots and that were allowed to
go on for months on end and that you
know were you outraged by that if you're
given those two options i guarantee the
vast majority of
the actual nfl audience
will choose the latter option for that
but he's 500 000 for it and uh but
apology find a hundred thousand dollars
still not enough um especially to the um
woke mob over on espn here's stephen a
smith
and ryan clark talking about the uh
you know
giving their reflections on on all of
this let's listen
he's white
he's not black
and there's an awful lot of white people
that cannot in any way identify with the
plight that african americans feel
physically emotionally spiritually
subliminally the list goes on and on and
on when are we going to stop expecting
them to do that
we have to get to a point where we look
at a jack del rio and what he said
and actually be gratified that there was
somebody that was willing to be open
about their ignorance
guess why jack del rio shouldn't be
a vilified he shouldn't be somebody
that's excoriated and nobody wants to
talk to them again know what black
people should be willing to do they
should be able to willing to walk right
up to jack the real hey how you doing
let's have a conversation about what you
said let me use this as an opportunity
to educate you
because if we're even gonna have any
hope towards making this world a better
place
making somebody cower and hide and
muzzle themselves and never feeling free
to speak up only disguises what they're
feeling which harbors and harnesses the
ignorance therefore they walk around
feeling ignorant being oblivious to the
kind of things that plague them
and us and our society and none of us
get any better but when he was willing
to be open i found nothing offensive to
turn this off please
i can't listen to this guy these people
are so stupid
sportscomb not all of them i mean well
it seems like all of them but no not all
on espn like the vast majority very very
stupid and stephen a smith
i my theory with steven a smith is that
his teleprompter is just a thesaurus and
they're cycling through random words and
he's just pulling words at random uh
that sound like they're big words and
make sense and that's how he ends up
saying well they can't relate to the the
plight of african americans subliminally
what
what what are you talking about the
subliminal plight of african americans
and when they when they're unable to
speak it it harnesses
and harvests their ignorance what are
you saying
i mean those are words but they don't
make sense when you put them together
you understand like you need you need to
have words and you have to have like
other words in between those words that
make it all work together you can't just
throw words out
um but he says stephen a smith says that
uh jack del rio can't can't relate can't
relate to the plight the subliminal
plights whatever that is
of african-americans uh stephen a smith
by the way his salary is eight million
dollars a year
um so this is a guy
on tv every day he makes a living just
shouting into a camera
which nothing against that obviously but
and he gets paid eight million dollars a
year to do it
and uh he's accusing other people of
being out of touch of not being able to
what's what's your plight stephen smith
how difficult is your life
really when you go out in public you're
you're you're afraid that you're going
to be persecuted by the police
really are you
see i don't i don't quite buy that
and they again this is what this is what
the commentators in espn are doing
people on the left are doing
they are saying that if you criticize
riots
that cause two billion dollars in
damages
and you know uh
dozens of people injured and killed
uh riots from which
many communities still have not
recovered
okay
small business owners
having their businesses burned to the
ground
um
people who work at you know just
a cvs a gas station
whatever are are forced to deal with
this they lose their jobs they've got
mobs coming in stealing
um
you know there's kids in in uh
at children's hospitals cancer patients
who are upstairs in in fear trembling in
fear as the mob and the riots are you
know people are
down in the streets
just outside the building
so if you look at all that and you say
i'm opposed to that
i think that's bad
then that then you are anti-black you
are an anti-black racist
so what exactly are you trying to say
that to oppose violent riots is
anti-black
what what are you i mean this is way
beyond bigotry of low expectations
there's just no expectations here at all
so that once again to me seems like the
actual racist degrading
uh viewpoint here
all right i want to
call your attention it's important that
i call your attention to this if you
haven't seen it there's a viral
twitter thread
by a user who goes by tulip r uh on on
twitter
this is according to
his bio a detransitioned adult male
and as we're talking about everything
with uh my film and with the also the
now the book
uh and all these issues we know about
the interview with
scott nugent that people found to be you
know probably most powerful part of the
film i also found it to be the most
powerful part of the film
um there are lots of stories like scott
nugent's
and i think also
the
so-called gender affirmation surgery
which used to be called which is a
euphemism used to be sex change and even
that was a euphemism right this is just
mutilation and butchery
i think still a lot of people don't
don't realize what goes into it so i
want to read some of this thread to you
and it gets pretty graphic
but uh it's important for us to
understand this is what this is what
quote-unquote doctors are doing this is
what's happening
to kids and adults
so he says i want to tell everyone what
they took from us what irreversible
really means and what that reality looks
like for us no one told me any of what
i'm going to tell you now
he says i have no sensation in my crotch
region at all you could stab me with a
knife and i wouldn't know the entire
area is numb like it's shell shocked and
unable to comprehend what happened even
four years on some of these tweets have
been removed by the way and twitter has
not given any explanation for that so
there's a long thread a lot of it's
still there but twitter has gone in and
removed certain parts of this story i'm
not sure which which parts have now been
removed
um he continues no one told me that the
base area of your penis is left it can't
be removed meaning you're left with a
literal stump inside that twitches when
you take testosterone and your libido
returns you wake up with morning wood
without the tree i wish this was a joke
that's something that will never come
back and one reason why i got surgery
my sex drive died about six months on
hrt and at that time i was glad to be
rid of it but now 10 years later i'm
realizing what i'm missing out on and
what i won't get back
because even if i had a sex drive my neo
vagina is so narrow and small i wouldn't
even be able to have sex if i wanted to
and when i do use a small dilator i have
random pockets of sensation that only
seem to pick up pain rather than
pleasure
uh any pleasure i do i do get comes from
the prostate that was moved forward and
wrapped in glands from the penis meaning
anal sex isn't possible and can risk
further damage
uh and then this goes on i've you know
this this goes on for a while talking
about the um
the actual day-to-day reality
that people are living through after
this has been done to them
he says a little bit later on then
there's the act of going to the toilet
it takes me about 10 minutes to empty my
bladder it's extremely slow painful and
because it dribbles no matter how much i
relax it will then just go all over that
entire area leaving me soaked so after
cleaning myself up i'll find moments
later that my underwear is wet no matter
how much i wiped it slowly drips out for
the best part of an hour i never knew at
35 i ran the risk of like of smelling
like piss everywhere i went
um
and then the story goes on and it's it's
you could go and read
you don't want to read stories like this
because it's so horrifying but again
this is what's actually this is what
doctors are doing and this is what they
are selling to kids
and condemning people to a life
of this
okay this medical experimentation
treating people like lab rats just kind
of that's what they're doing
just experimenting okay let's uh let's
take this body part off let's move this
stuff around here and then this
and all in in pursuit
of something that is impossible
okay
i mean you you might as well you the
doctors might as well take somebody's
arms off and replace them with wings
and tell them that now they can fly
now not only worse
not only can they fly but now you're a
bird
because we took your arms off and put
wings on no you'll you'll never be a
bird
you cover yourself in feathers putting
wings on you're never gonna be a bird
you're still a human
now you're just deformed
and it's the same thing here
you're a man you will never ever ever be
a woman it will never happen
it cannot happen
you don't have the parts you ha you have
a penis not a vagina you will never have
a vagina you will never have one
what they can do is cut a hole in you
around the crotch area and they can call
it a vagina but it's not
and it turns out that when they do that
there are all kinds of
lifelong
[Music]
horrifying uh you can't even call them
complications because their complication
sounds like it wasn't intended or
there's you know no this is not a
complication it's just lifelong
consequences that you're going to live
with forever
this kind of walking nightmare and
there's so many stories like this of
people who de-transitioned
so that brings me to a point that i've
made and i think is really important
that
it is
beyond
uh infuriating to think that we do this
to kids right and and
anyone who says that it should be okay
to do anything like this to a child is
just a monster
anyone who would do anything like this
to a child or who thinks that we should
do anything like this to a child if you
support this then there are two options
either you are completely insane
or one of the dumbest people to ever
walk the earth or you are an absolute
moral monster
right one of those two
and that's for kids
so any any sane reasonable person we can
all agree on that
but it's also horrifying and wrong when
they do it to adults it should not be
legal to do this to anyone i don't care
if they're an adult or not
this person underwent this procedure in
their it sounds like as an
adult um for 20s or 30s
but does that make it okay
does that mean that that
they were in the right frame of mind
could they really consent to this like
the fact that they're magically so
they're over the age of uh 18 and so
then there are no other concerns at all
like it's not possible that there could
be other mental problems going on which
means that they they still can't really
consent to something like this the fact
that if you want this done to you
that is proof already
that you're not in the mental state
required to consent to have this done to
you
that is proof in and of itself that you
have deep deep mental problems that need
to be treated
it should not be legal do this anyone
and every time i bring that point up i'm
uh even some conservatives will say well
so what you you're you're saying i mean
they're consenting adults so should an
adult be able to consent
shouldn't people be able to do what they
want with their own bodies
we're not talking about what adults do
to their own bodies we're talking about
what doctors
with medical licenses are doing to
people's bodies
and no i don't think that doctors should
be able to just do anything to a
person's body as long as that person is
an adult and said they want it done
does anyone think that
is that really what anyone thinks a
doctor should be able to do anything at
all to a person's body as long as that
person's an adult and they say please do
it to me
it should not be illegal to do this to
anybody
okay this is the the the way this
affects kids is a big part of the story
it's not the whole story
just the whole under this is one of the
things we try to do in the film
we're going after the underlying premise
here
it is all built on a lie
and if you're lying to a kid and saying
we can chop up your body and turn you
into a different sex that's horrible if
you're lying to an adult and telling
them that it's also horrible
i think we need to be very clear about
that
let's get to the comment section
do you know their name
[Music]
uh let's see croots says the family
looks perfectly happy now we're talking
about the family of the quote unquote
trans quote-unquote trans kid who quote
unquote transitioned at the age of five
crude says the family looks perfectly
happy funny to see matt spurge out at
the site of a successful transition that
doesn't fit his narrative oh right yeah
um they're they're they they look well
they're smiling on camera so that means
everything's fine is that what you think
what they smile on camera they must be
perfectly happy
it's it's not like there's a it's not
like there's a this is
a known thing on social media where
people can present themselves as happy
and they're living a wonderful life and
then you get under the surface and it
turns out that's not the case
no you're right you're right uh croots
that anyone who smiles on camera
is happy
and certainly any child who says that
sits with their parents and says i'm
happy is happy so you know what if uh if
there's reports credible reports of uh
of child abuse going on in inside a home
if the if the child comes out to cps and
stands with the parents and says oh i'm
happy everything's fine here and smiles
then right the cps you just turn around
well he said he's happy he wouldn't lie
is that what you think
you freaking [ __ ]
you you actually think so a toddler can
transition their gender that's that's
your that's your view
successful transition of a toddler
you maniac so this is a good example
here of uh like i said either you are
one of the dumbest people to ever live
on earth or you're an absolute monster
i'll let you and you can decide that for
yourself
friendly river media says the fox
segment is seriously like a parody based
on the things map exposed and what is a
woman i'm glad people are calling it out
lots of people are calling it out but i
think even more need to uh because fox
still has not they've just tried to move
on from this
there's not any apology
or even a justification
like how about how about let's start
with explain to us fox why you felt the
need to air this segment
and to air it worst of all during the
news portion
of your programming what's supposed to
be a news
broadcast
and you air it not even acknowledging so
you're talking about
quote trans kids
you don't even acknowledge
that there is any opposing view here
like pretending that the criticisms that
it's just it's just self-evident
that we should transition five-year-olds
that's what they did on fox
um
let's see i lost my place here
evan says matt my one minor criticism of
what is a woman is that you didn't have
time to cover these neurotic parents who
need a trans kid because it's all about
them
mommy munchausen as you say here this
story is why i think it's so important
uh we tried we we tried to we tried to
get some parents in the in the
munchausen community
with the with the very young trans kids
we tried to get some of them to talk to
us and none of them would
um because it turns out that uh they
don't want to put themselves in a
position of having to actually explain
any of this
they'll do the puff pieces okay so if
you show up and you're just gonna do a
puff piece and tell them how brave and
wonderful they are they're more than
happy for that and they'll bring their
kid out they'll parade their kid around
on camera
but if they think there's any
if they get a whiff of a hint
that you might ask a real question then
they don't want to go anywhere near it
because these parents they know what
they're doing
but we did try not for lack of trying
morgan says matt it's not just that
we're not allowed guns in canada for
self-defense we cannot have anything
it is illegal for a woman to carry
pepper spray in her purse for
self-defense you can't even buy it here
i that i did not realize
and it just leads me back to the same
question of uh
what why would why live in canada at
this point
i understand if you're born there and
it's where you're born but uh what what
like what's the good part
that's what i'd like to know actually
from actual canadians maybe in the
comments
i could think of a million reasons not
to live in canada
what's uh what's the plus side and how
does it outweigh the negative
at this point
dusty says why is he saying no other
network would ever air something like
this there have been plenty of trans
documentaries over the years what
they're saying is typical and what you
would come to expect from a trans news
piece has he never heard of jazz
jennings or seen the 60-minute specials
from back in like the early 2000s lol
obviously we see promotion of trans kids
all over the media my point is that
there were elements of this piece that
arguably
would be too far at this point for cnn
or msnbc specifically
and i think the one that comes to mind
is the claim
that a child chose her gender before she
could speak so this is an outright out
in the open
promotion of
gender transitioning
babies
and yeah i do think that it's it's
somewhat splitting hairs right because
if if you if this would not be on cnn at
this point it will be in the future
um and they get pretty close to it
anyway but uh yeah that is my my point
is just to emphasize how
radical that is
this is not fox like dipping their toe
in the water here
okay they're going they're jumping right
into the deep end with with transgender
babies
that's what fox is doing and one reason
why again we need to hold them
accountable for that
well my new book as mentioned what is a
woman is available now the what is a
woman film was a huge success and if you
like the film you've got to read the
book the book dives even deeper into the
interviews and topics featured in the
film so be sure to pick up your copy of
my brand new book what is a woman today
on amazon or wherever you buy books but
again amazon is where i prefer just
because it's a lot funnier there tonight
also is the premiere of our summer
blockbuster tara on the prairie two days
after disney tried to cancel gina carano
daily wire swooped in and uh said that
uh we're gonna pick her up and she's
gonna star in the film and tonight is
the premiere of her brand new film with
the daily wire terror on the prairie
tara on the prairie is a gritty western
and gina's personal redemption story
shines through in her leading role it's
a great film too i can tell you she
doesn't pull any punches as a frontier
woman fighting for survival in the
brutal american west plus it's produced
by our friend dallas sonja who brought
you bone tomahawk with kurt russell so
you know you know what you're getting
into and it's just it really delivers i
can tell you so go to dailywire.comgina
and tune in tonight at 8 30 p.m eastern
for the pre-show 9 pm eastern for the
world premiere of the film and stick
around for a q a following the film head
to
dailywire.com gina right now now let's
get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
our daily cancellation begins with one
of our favorite characters in this
segment lizzo except that for once the
story has almost nothing to do with
lizzo being naked and overweight as we
know she's built a career around
exploring the intersection of fatness
and nakedness but that is not the point
today rather lizzo has attracted
controversy because of some of the
lyrics in her new hit single
girls
spelled g-r-r-r-l-s
as we know lizzo almost certainly cannot
define the word girl
but perhaps she can define the word girl
i don't know but this is not the word
that has caused severe offense
consternation emotional trauma and even
we must assume physical injury to some
of uh of lizzo's fans
that word well i'm not going to tell you
what that word is
partly because it's so deeply
problematic and shocking that i dare not
speak it out loud and also because i
thought it'd be a fun game
to play a one minute clip of the song
for you
and i want you to guess
which lyric was so offensive that lizzo
had to issue a public apology and
re-release the song with this word
changed
so listen closely
hold my back
do you see this
i'm a spaz i'm about to knock somebody
i'll go with my best friend she the only
one i know to talk me off the deep end
cause that's my girl we co-dependent if
she waited then i'm waiting yeah we
touch so much business
blue that's my girl we ceos and dancing
like a seahorse we about to throw them
bows let's get up where are my girls
from my girls
where are my girls from my girls
[Music]
ratchet with my friends
[Music]
once again proving herself to be the
greatest poet of our time or any time
shakespeare may have written a clever
line or two but he never would have
thought
to write something like
yeah we tussle mind your business zoo
zoo zoo zoo zoo zulu that's my girl we
ceos and dancing like a ce ho
only lizzo could come up with something
so profound and moving if shakespeare
had written that they would have you
know assumed he was having a stroke or
something
but we're dancing around the point here
indeed i dare say we are we are even
dancing like ce hoes around the point
the question we still must answer is
which word out of all of the words you
just heard
though maybe bit too generous to call
all of those words
which was considered objectionable
enough to necessitate changing the song
she says the word [ __ ] multiple times
she uses the word hoe multiple times she
drops f-bomb she uses the term boozy
ratchet whatever the hell that means the
whole thing is about her engaging acts
of violence the song is one big threat
to jump some unspecified person and
commit felony assault or worse
and it's a potentially dangerous message
too because it might inspire other
out-of-shape women to pick random fights
with strangers thinking that they can
knock somebody out when they've never
thrown a punch in their lives and
probably will just break their wrists if
they tried
so
is that the problematic message
or how about the part where lizzo says
that she's gonna cut a man's penis off
so that he can never have sex again
that's pretty disrespectful is that the
offensive part
the entire song from beginning to end is
vulgar stupid and violent
she could scrap the whole thing and
replace all the lyrics with the sounds
of feral cats fighting inside a dumpster
and it would be a vast improvement over
what you just heard so
what is the specific line that caused
the problem
well it turns out
that the only offensive word in that
song was the word
spazz
now if you recall at the very beginning
she sings hold my bag hold my bag do you
see this
i'm a spaz
again
pure poetry
but that's the problem right there i'm a
spaz quite literally the least offensive
word in the entire song one of the only
lyrics that that we don't have to bleep
on this show is the word that people are
offended by of course
as entertainment weekly reports the term
spazz is now as of about 12 seconds ago
uh considered an ableist slur
in fact in their report entertainment
weekly censors the word much like they
would if it was the n word or the f word
which is still written out
in the in the article
but spazz or the s word as it will now
be known
is censored
many of lizzo's fans took her to task
for ableism in her song which promotes
felony violence and forced castration
but the real problem is the ableism
one of the fans leading the charge was
hannah divani a disability advocate with
pronouns in her bio and she tweeted a
couple of days ago she said hey lizzo my
disability cerebral palsy is literally
classified as [ __ ] dipl
diplegia where
specificity spasticity refers to
unending painful tightness in my legs
your new song makes me pretty angry and
sad spazz doesn't mean freaked out or
crazy it's an ableist slur
it's 20 22. do better
yes it's 2022. you should know better
than to use harmless slang while
threatening to cut a man's penis off and
beat stranger senseless for no reason
please stick to communicating your
violent fantasies with vulgarities and
profanity just please just stick with
that
hannah is a woman of principle and
that's what she demands
and she got her way pretty quickly
yesterday lizzo reissued the song with
the s word replaced
and she made a public apology she posted
a twitter quote it's been brought to my
attention that there's a harmful word in
my new song girls let me make one thing
clear i never want to promote derogatory
language as a fat black woman in america
i've had many hurtful words used against
me so i overstand the power words can
have wait
i overstand
okay
i overstand the power words can have
whether intentionally or in my case
unintentionally i'm proud to say that
there's a new version of girls with a
lyric changed this is the result of me
listening and taking action
as an influential artist i'm dedicated
to being part of the change i've been
wanting and waiting to see in the world
only lizzo could manage to call herself
influential say that she's proud of
herself and brag about her wisdom and
insight
all in the context of an apology
truly the woman has turned virtue
signaling into an art form
she hasn't quite figured out how to make
her music into an art form but she's
basically the beethoven of virtue
signaling
at any rate yes uh be the change you
want to see in the world and lizzo
apparently
wants a world that is confused overly
sensitive and has its priorities exactly
backwards and upside down
and there's no doubt that she's
certainly helping in her own small way
to create precisely that kind of world
actually i need to correct myself
because i think we make a mistake when
we say that this sort of thing
is an example of people being sensitive
okay
and i and i say that all the time but
it's not exactly true because
traditionally a sensitive person is
somebody who is empathetic kind um
deeply aware of other people's feelings
and needs they're affected by and will
respond to
social cues
facial expressions and so on a sensitive
person is caring and compassionate
it's good to be sensitive in that way
and i say that as someone who is pretty
far to the other end of the spectrum for
better or worse
but i'm married to that sort of
sensitive person and i could say for
sure that the world would be a better
place if there were many more people
like her in the world like my wife
that's why if this was simply a case of
people being sensitive about the song
they might listen to it and object to
the whole thing observing that it's
vulgar and obscene and contributes to
the coarsening of our culture that would
be a sensitive and certainly not at all
unreasonable or baseless reaction to the
song and to almost everything else pop
culture produces but that's not what's
happening here
the people who who we often call
sensitive
are not sensitive at all
far from sensitive they're numb and dumb
they're more like robots filtering
everything through their leftist
programming and deciding based on those
algorithms to pretend to be offended by
all of the wrong things
this is how we end up in a culture
overrun by a bunch of inverted prudes
puritans who have been turned inside out
and flipped upside down
they have an endless appetite for
debauchery vulgarity stupidity obscenity
but they recoil in hard start firing off
angry letters because of some random
totally benign word or phrase that
happens to step on the intersectional
tripwire and set off the pc alarms
they celebrate christina aguilera
dancing around in front of children with
a strap-on dildo but if she had her hair
braided like in a you know a
dreadlocks or something
then they would demand a public apology
for cultural appropriation and hairstyle
colonialism
this is the kind of sensitivity we're
talking about
and it's not sensitivity at all
but insanity
i think that's what we should really be
saying
and that is why not just lizzo but
everybody involved in this story
is today
cancelled
and you're all a bunch of spazzes too
might i add
that'll do it for us today thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo vladovsky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22. today on the ben shapiro show the
stock market officially hits bear market
territory as the fed desperately seeks
to tamp down inflation the january 6th
committee keeps rehashing the stuff we
already knew and pride month continues
with perverse displays in front of small
children that's today on the bench here
show give it a listen